first of all that's rude what you just
did i liked it whitney that was funny
yeah yeah yeah yeah that was what you
just did
yeah because uh
you know why can't a man look at his
girlfriend a friend of you know and go
nice nipples yeah why can't that happen
and it's just it's not it's not a sexual
thing i've never looked at you in a
sexual way it's a respect thing i mean i
look at you like uh i look like ronan
pharaoh because i i actually prefer
sexual abuse to emotional abuse and
that's what you're doing right now
i've never wanted to have sex with you
the only thing worse than a guy
is actually harassing you is
emotionally harassing okay let me read
her
let me restate what i just said then
okay
let me try to get to all right
obviously you're attractive and there
are men that like you right i just don't
find you attractive that's my own
personal page
why are you
why are you mocking the person that
thinks i'm not i got this i'm not doing
it you have downs
why are you doing an impression of your
brother when you do that guys that look
like ryan reynolds guys that look like
ryan reynolds yeah you mean handsome
dudes with pecs you know what i mean and
six packs
but they're also very stop giving kala
ideas of people today
yeah yeah
but i just so i you know i looked at
your nipples and i it was not in the
sexual way i put it in a higher register
nice nipples same again
try it higher oh nice nipples perfect
yeah that's good is that better i don't
think any nipples to men are not nice
like
when i think that they're i think that a
lot of the like
breast hating about it comes from our
women ourselves yeah i think so when i
made that robot uh i went to the sex
robot factory and they told me the
number one request from men when they
were customizing to make more noise
um
pandora's boxing all right all right go
ahead no sorry no no no i i what you
could do but now i have something to say
i had a whole plan of something i was
going to say on top of course i don't
know why
of course we're already talking about
nipples um
that the number one request from people
that have sex uh make sex dolls is dark
very large nipples big areolas that's
kind of weird because think about it
whitney um women when they get pregnant
and prepare for breastfeeding their
nipples become charcoal looking because
it allows the baby for more contrast
when the baby's eyes
exactly so like men just are babies
black nipples so your nipples turn into
x-men
dude
they turn into mystique mystique
they're like a mood ring yeah yeah um
and yeah exactly and then larger and
then they have to get larger
larger
i have a question
why do you keep referring it to a robot
is it a doll or a robot it's a sex robot
he's gonna have a female what i'm saying
is a robot is has you know i mean talk
and it's animatronic right okay i get it
you don't follow me on instagram um i've
only posted about it for three years
straight no i've seen it i've just never
seen it move does it talk and whatnot
it's a doll when it's off and it's a
robot when it's on and when you turn it
on what does it do uh it can talk it can
engage with you i did not know so my bad
it is a robot my bad it is a robot these
questions have there are reasons for
this question he's he's going to try to
court your robot next
please no yeah by the way
it would go great with all these
weird-ass [ __ ] statues you have in
your
in your foyer wait i just found out that
um we've collectively as a society been
having sex
the wrong way uh-huh hold up i want to
have one i just want to say one last
thing about your robot does it have a
vaginal plaque part it does and i put
pantyho
there's a hole that you can stick your
penis in yes okay i don't want it then
go ahead
that was the thing
i mean you could take someone else's
penis in and watch i mean yeah what
you're into what about if it had a penis
no i wouldn't wha i'm not gay baby okay
can i see something just really fast
yeah claim my space here yeah i we've
all been touring a lot and now that the
pandemic's over seeing i'm going to say
something sincere mm-hmm go ahead i'm
going to say something sincere
for once
go ahead uh so i just did i don't know
50 cities or you know we had to make up
all those dates and you know um shot a
special like at the end and was getting
ready to shoot the special and when i
say
that the tiger belly fans
are the most
gracious